prudence conducteur devra l'être sur la
route quand bien même il arriverait au
volant de la fameuse citroën sm ce coupé
à deux portes et quatre places que cette
firme française présente en première
mondiale au salon de genève et que les
limougeauds ont pu voir lors de la
présentation qui en a été faite à
limoges tout récemment un moteur
maserati dont les 6 cylindres en v offre
leur 2006 170 centimètres cubes et qui
pour une puissance fiscale française de
15 chevaux développe une puissance
réelle de 180 chevaux à 6000 250 tours
minute
l'aérodynamisme de ce coupé qui présente
à l'avancé b d'aération pour le
refroidissement du moteur s'harmonisent
fort bien d'une large rampes d'éclairage
repent trois par trois six projecteurs
et lonza iode tous équipés d'un
dispositif hydraulique de correction
d'assiette automatique
le confort de cette carrosserie très
clair à l'intérieur la surface totale
des glaces atteignant presque 3 mètres
carrés est avant tout une résultante de
la suspension qui en fait la renommée
puisque l'asm dispose d'un système de
suspension hydraulique amortisseurs
intégrer
[Musique]
la position du volant lui même nous
allons le voir est réglable dans tous
les angles et la direction assistée
bénéficie d'un régulateur centrifuges
qui détermine les forts à exercer sur le
volant de telle sorte que cet effort
varie avec la vitesse du véhicule les
roues elle même subi ça rappel
automatique vers la position de ligne
droite même à l'arrêt il n'y aurait pas
de belles voitures automobiles sans un
tableau de bord soigner et complet c'est
le cas de l'asm puisque des aérateurs
réglable un cadran d'indications de
vitesses graduée jusqu'à 260 km/heure
voisine avec un compte-tours
électronique de 8000 tours-minute tous
ses cadres en est sans doute un instant
rêveur celui ou celle qui prennent place
pour la première fois dans ces sièges
baquets réglable dans tous sens et qui
sont certainement une fort belle
invitation au voyage
et c'est le départ avec en première
vitesse plus de 60 kilomètres heure pour
atteindre par rapide paliers jusqu'à ce
niveau de la cinquième vitesse de cette
boîte entièrement synchroniser les
quelques 220 km en 1h que promet cette
nouvelle traction avant sm citoyenne et
la voilà partie en sécurité sur la route
avec une réserve de 90 litres d'essence
donnant à cette utilisatrice une
autonomie déclarent les constructeurs de
700 km environ
un rêve et une réalité
[Musique]